right now that we have a rare first-hand
account from the center of maybe the
greatest scandal in modern political
history the FBI spying on the 2016 Trump
campaign for nearly two years Obama
administration officials and their
dutiful lackeys in the press
hysterically denied any of that even
happened now we know that it did happen
the Obama administration used government
agencies to surveil a rival campaign
there's no denying that now so instead
the usual apologists are claiming it was
a good thing in fact they were spying on
Trump to protect him and by the way you
have no right to know anything about it
even asking a question as a sign of
disloyalty shut up and obey no thanks
tonight we have a direct account of what
happened the first full interview of the
Trump campaign official who apparently
was targeted by an FBI spy Sam Clovis
was a former national co-chairman of the
Trump campaign in September of 2016 he
says he had a face-to-face meeting with
a man who was believed to be one of the
FBI spies on that campaign Sam Clovis
joins us tonight Sam thanks for coming
on so thanks doctor thanks for having me
on you believe you had a face-to-face
encounter with the man paid by Obama's
FBI to spy on your campaign describe
that meeting if you would several days
before the September first meeting I had
the opportunity to receive emails from
Steven Stefan Halper dr. Halperin sent
emails using the Emperor mater of him
knowing
Carter page and asked for a sit-down
with me he just wanted to come in and
discuss foreign policy and to provide so
it what he thought might be his some of
his writings that would be able to
contribute and help us in the and the
campaign I arranged that meeting we had
that meeting in Washington DC on the 1st
of September it lasted about an hour had
the opportunity to discuss over coffee
with him his research and it mostly was
focused on China and then I think after
that meeting and on the 27th of
September I received an email from him
with several attachments and I can be
honest with you
Tucker I haven't even opened those
attachments to this day I have no idea
what was in them but they
mostly titled papers that dealt with
China I think he used my meeting as a
using my meeting as a bonafide he's with
George papadopolis to have a meeting
with him that I did not know about it
was subsequent to to my meeting with him
on the first of September so you didn't
know him before he mailed you Cole no I
did not when did you begin it was a I'm
sorry go ahead no I just got the email
from from Stefan that asked for the
meeting and he used the fact that he
knew Carter page and court Carter had
been associated with our campaign at
what point did you begin to suspect he
was working for the FBI seeking to
gather information surreptitiously on
the campaign
well Mart meeting was like two faculty
members in the faculty lounge so I
didn't think anything of it until I saw
the reporting that started to come out
only recently and then I started to put
two and two together and then it started
to make sense to me that perhaps he was
probing to find a weak spot in our
campaign someone who might be vulnerable
to connecting things back to those
elusive 30,000 emails that supposedly
the Russians had and I really think that
was what his task was was to fund it to
create an audit trail back to those
emails from someone in the campaign or
someone associated with the campaign so
that they could develop a stronger case
for probable cause to continue to issue
warrants and and and to further an
investigation because I really felt
after hearing all of these other things
and listening to the reports that I've
read that this truly was an effort to
build something that did not exist and I
really think that was what his mission
was why haven't you read the attachments
to Z mails well at one I was busy I
worked 16 to 20 hours a day we already
had a lot of help on on foreign policy
in the areas of China I really didn't
think that they were going to contribute
anything and frankly I've got back and
reviewed all my
males I didn't report that meeting to
anyone in the campaign so the meeting
was of no consequence to me as far as
anything I could remember and I have
looked through all of my personal emails
and and everything and I can't find a
record of it at all interesting but that
meeting may have played a key role in a
much larger story Sam thank you for that
account appreciate it that's great
thanks for having me on tonight Tucker
appreciate it thank you